If you’ve ever skied on a mountain
covered in artificial snow, you have a microbe to thank.
To make snow, ski resorts use a protein,
Ina Z from a bacteria that in nature damages plants
by jump-starting the freezing process
inside leaves.
To better understand this freezing power,
researchers used a special laser-based spectroscopy
technique.
They found that inaZ arranges water molecules
into the right formation to create ice—
and it also aligns water into alternating
tightly packed and loosely packed stripes.
Ice is more likely to form at the line
where those stripes meet the protein.
Plus, the  protein funnels heat away
from water as it freezes,
helping the process along.
Since the microbes also contribute to
the production of snow and rain in the atmosphere,
understanding more about the bacteria’s icy abilities
could help researchers make better predictions
about climate change.